[Musique]
et comment devient tôt hauteur quand on
s'appelle balasko et que personne ne
vous connaît
au départ je voulais faire la décoration
voulait faire des petits mickey comme ça
que j'étais pas disons entre
excessivement doué pour ça alors je vous
dis tiens je choisir un métier qui
rapporte plus lui faire comédienne
j'étais questier au théâtre de poche
montparnasse à l'époque donc j'avais
toute la journée derrière un bureau à
répondre aux questions alors j'avais
emprunté la machine à écrire du théâtre
et je me suis mis à écrire un spectacle
que j'étais une fille bon pour deux
filles pour notre copine à moi aussi et
qui s'appelait quand je serai grande je
serai paranoïaque
le spectacle de sketches mais une fille
qui vendait des bérets suicide dans le
métro des comités des bérets il
explosait il y avait deux bonnes soeurs
qui étaient un peu disons un peu drogués
une une femme qui était qui sont son
mari est un homme chien fait un truc
comme ça est un peu fou et à la fin on
se suicider
d'où le titre et puis on l'a joué donc
au café-théâtre de vidéos après on est
parti à avignon et c'était un des
premiers spectacles où il y avait deux
filles
enfin il n'était pas tellement là encore
la grande mode et des one man show ou
des to women show savait pas trop mal
marché c'était c'était marrant c'était
puis c'était la première fois que je
jouais devant un public et que je voyais
que ça faisait rire les gens quand ça
s'est arrêté je me suis dit il faut que
je continue
alors je me suis créé un spectacle pour
moi tout seul qui s'appelle la pipelette
ne plie pas plus un peu plus sur moi
même c'est à dire un peu plus en parlant
de deux choses plus précises stimule
quoi ma taille mon physique
lunel tout ça et je les jouais rue
d'odessa dans un passage qui est aussi
démoli maintenant c'est après m'avoir vu
dans la plaie de la peep a plus que
francis faire m'a demandé de travailler
avec lui sur un scénario et c'est devenu
pauline et l'ordinateur
l'histoire d'une nana qui a des
problèmes et pauline c'était moi j'ai de
la marge
[Musique]
60 kg pour avoir un truc pas pris un
kilo moins une minute
alors on tortues poissons qu'on rame en
rideau j'ai pas mangé ma tartine alors
comment vous est venue l'idée d'écrire
but nice bar ou plutôt les hommes
préfèrent les grosses bas au départ s'il
avait envie d'écrire une pièce avec des
comédiens bien précis le thème de la
pièce c'est une femme qui s'en va et une
autre qui vient ça se passe dans les
vestiaires d'un cabaret c'est à dire
l'entrée n arrive adam vestiaire qui
s'appelle anita de que je joue qui va
partir sa dernière nuit elle a travaillé
pendant deux trois ans dans cette boîte
comme dame vestiaire à l'abbaye aux
dames pipi ou il est deux à la vie tout
court elle fait le vestiaire a levé les
yeux tout ça avant l été puni en bois
c'est à dire qu'elles servaient les gens
en petite tenue
salehi arrêté tout ça et comme elle a
grossi à monter ou aux vestiaires
[Musique]